[موسيقى]
صواريخ ايران البالسيه هدف جديد على اجنده
الضربات الاسرائيليه وجنوب افريقيا تسعى
لمنافسه الكبار في عالم صناعه المسيرات
اهلا بكم في عسكريتانيا
تكشف عن خطط موسكو لتعزيز احدث فرقاطاتها
بصواريخ بعيده المدى هذه الصواريخ ستمكنها
من الاشتباك مع طائرات الانذار المبكر
المحموله جوا بعيده المدى التابعه لحلف
النيتو حيث تعمل روسيا حاليا على تطوير
فرقاطات فئه الادميرال جورجكوف 22 350 امت
والمجهزه بانظمه دفاع جوي لتتمكن من حمل
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات يصل مداها الى 400
كيلو متر بدلا من الصواريخ الحاليه والتي
يصل مداها الى 150 كيلو متر فقط ينتظر
الجيش التركيه استلام دبابه الطاي والتي
تعد اول دبابه محليه الصنع في مايو القادم
لتبدا بعد ذلك مرحله من الاختبارات
الميدانيه والتي من المتوقع ان تستمر حتى
عام 2025
الدبابه الطاي والتي تنتجها شركه بي ام سي
والتي تعد شراكه تركيه قطريه تم تزويدها
بناقل حركه وكذلك محرك ديزل من شركات من
كوريا الجنوبيه
الهند تخصص نحو 20 مليار دولار من ميزانيه
هذا العام لشراء اسلحه وكذلك منظومات
دفاعيه جديده حيث تسعى لتعزيز قدراتها
الدفاعيه في ظل تصاعد التهديدات الحاليه
وكذلك تصاعد حده التوترات مع بكين ستشمل
التعزيزات الجديده شراء مسيرات جويه
وبحريه وكذلك انظمه للدفاع الصاروخيه
[موسيقى]
خلال السنوات الاخيره عززت ايران بشكل
متسارع من قدراتها الصاروخيه وتحديدا
الصواريخ بعيده المدى على الجانب الاخر
جاءت الضربات الاسرائيليه الاخيره لتكشف
تحول في اولويات تل ابيب من وقف برنامج
طهران النوويه للحد من قدرتها الصاروخيه
وتحديدا الصواريخ بعيده المدى هذا تحديدا
بعدما ارسلت الوكلائها في سوريا ولبنان
اجزاء وقطع من هذه الصواريخ للوقوف على
ابعاد هذا التحول الاستراتيجي في السياسه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه اكثر معنى السيده
مايكل ايزن ستاد مدير برنامج الدفاع
والامن في معهد واشنطن لدراسات الشرق
الادنى اولا مصر مايكل اهلا بك معنا في
عسكري تيريا بدايه لماذا كل هذا التخوف
الاسرائيلي من برنامج ايران للصواريخ
وتحديدا الصواريخ بعيده المدى
فهي منشات ظاهره ومعروف مواقعها الى حد
كبير لكن برايك هل هذا سيشجع الجانب
الاسرائيلي على مزيد من استهداف مثل هذه
المواقع في العمق الايراني
لقد حدث تحول في السنوات الاخيره في
استراتيجيه اسرائيل التي بدلا من التركيز
على الاهداف في بلاد الشام اي في سوريا
لان لبنان يمثل خطا احمر بسبب وجود حزب
الله لكنها تعمل على منع وصول الاسلحه
لحزب الله ايضا حولت اسرائيل تركيزها
باتجاه ايران لانها ادركت انها لن يكون
بوسعها تجاهل التطورات الحاصله في ايران
في مجال انتاج المسيرات التي يمكن ان
تستهدف اسرائيل من بلاد الشام الى جانب
تهديد الذي يمثله برنامج ايران نووي الذي
لا يواجه اي قيود في الوقت الراهن لذلك
فاسرائيل تسعى الى تعطيل هذه الانشطه فضلا
عن العمل على اطاله امد تطويرها
مستر مايكل ايران اعلنت مؤخرا انها حظائر
لطائرات تحت الارض لكن برايك هل ستنجح
ايران في اخفاء هذه المواقع عن اعين
الاستخبارات الامريكيه والاسرائيليه ام
ستنجح اجهزه الاستخبارات للولايات المتحده
وكذلك لاسرائيل في الوصول لمواقع هذه
الحضائر
ايران
لدى ايران برنامج طويل المدى خاص بتوفير
الحمايه لمنشاتها النوويه والصاروخيه
وعندما يتم حفر مخابئ للمنشات في باطن
الارض فهذا العمل بحد ذاته يبعث باشارات
والمرشح جدا انه لدى الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل معلومات جيده بشان اماكن هذه
المنشات وليس كلها وعند معرفه هذه المواقع
تبحث مساله اختيار السلاح المناسب لضربها
لكن المشكله تكمن في ان بعض المنشات
الايرانيه مثل محطه فوردو ومنشات تصنيع
الصواريخ تقع في عمق الارض تحت طبقات من
الخرسانه السميكه لكن ثمه طرق الحق اضرار
بهذه المنشات بدلا من اختراق تحصيناتها
العميقه فلو قطعت امدادات الطاقه عن مراكز
الطرد المركزي فانها يمكن ان تدمر نفسها
بنفسها في حال نفذ الهجوم بطريقه معينه
وهذا احد السبل الكفيله بالحاق الضرر بهذه
المنشات وايران على درايه بهذه المعطيات
وهو ما قد يكون قد دفعها لتطوير قدرات في
مجال الطاقه بعيده عن منشات تخسيب
اليورانيوم الامر يخص تغيرا مستمرا في
الموازنه بين مسعى ايران لحمايه قدراتها
ومنشاتها وحرص كل من الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل على ان تظل هذه القدرات
والمنشاءات ضعيفه انشوده
مستر مايكل دائما بعد كل عمليه تستهدف
منشات ايرانيه تتحدث الاجهزه الامنيه في
ايران عن انها سترد لكن على ارض الواقع لا
ترد باي شيء هل لدى ايران خيارات فعليه
للرد ام انه مثل هذه الاحاديث التي تخرج
من النظام هي مجرد دعايه اعلاميه لا اكثر
ولا اقل
اننا حاولنا خلال مفاوضات مع ايران بشان
الملف النووي وضع قيود على قدرات ايران
الصاروخيه لكن بالنسبه لايران تمثل
الصواريخ العمود الفقري لقواتها
الاستراتيجيه فقد شهدنا انها قد تقبل
قيودا على برنامجها النووي وليس على
البرنامج الصاروخي ربما قد يقال اننا لم
نسعى بما فيه الكفايه او نولي الاولويه
لهذا المسح غير انني لا اعتقد ان ايران
كانت ستقبل بوضع اي قيود على برنامجها
الصاروخي بالتالي تبقى الخيارات المتاحه
للتعامل مع هذا البرنامج تقتصر على تعطيل
البرنامج وتخريبه وهو مساعات كل من
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل للقيام به الى
ان ما احرز من تقدم في هذا الاتجاه ليس
بالقدر الكبير خاصه في مجال تصنيع ايران
للصواريخ البالستيه بعيده المدى
مستر مايكل بعد كل هذه السنوات هل نستطيع
القول بانه واش اخطات خطا استراتيجيا
حينما لم تضع قيود على برنامج ايران
للصواريخ الباليستيه وما هو السبيل لعلاج
هذه المشكله بشكل او باخر
اعتقد ان المناورات الاخيره التي كانت
الاكبر من نوعها بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل على الاطلاق ربما تعكس القلق لدى
البلدين بان البرنامج النووي الايراني لم
يتوقف وعلى الولايات المتحده واسرائيل ان
تجد سبلًا للتصدي لتهديد نووي الايراني
واقناعها بضروره الحد من انشطتها النوويه
والعدول عن مواصله تخصيب اليورانيوم حتى
درجه نقاء تصل الى 90% بعد ان بلغت نسبه
60% والمناورات تعد في جزء منها رادعه ولد
البلدين الرغبه في رؤيه ما سيكون عليه
الرد الايراني كما ان الولايات المتحده
سوف تجري مناورات مع حلفائها وشركائها
الاقليميين وقد نشهد ايضا مناورات بين
الولايات المتحده ودول عربيه واسرائيل في
لتوجيه رساله الى ايران مفادها ان ما تقوم
به ايران من انشطه يقوض مصالحنا وسوف نعمل
على الاخلال بالوضع الامني في ايران
مستر مايكل مؤخرا تزايدت تدريبات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه التي تحاكي هجوم
على منشات ايرانويه برايك هل مثل هذه
المناورات ستشكل قوه رضع بالنسبه لايران
ام انها ستمنح النظام الايراني فرصه لوجود
بدائل او لايجاد بدائل اخرى
نستطيع باعتقادها القول ان ايران حاولت
الرد لكن حتى الان حققت اسرائيل الكثير من
النجاحات في احباط محاولات رد الايرانيه
ومن وجهه نظر الايرانيه ثمه مخاطر تكمن في
التصعيد مع اسرائيل وقد شهدنا في الاونه
الاخيره تغيرا في تركيز ايران على استهداف
الجنود الامريكيين في العراق لما يسببه
هذا التوجه من تعطيل لمنظومه الحكم في
العراق كما تغير تركيزها على فيما يزعم
انها منشاه اسرائيليه في شمال العراق او
حتى الاهداف الكرديه لكن تحول ايران
احيانا استهداف الامريكيين عندما ترى ان
الولايات المتحده لن ترد على هذا
الاستهداف عكس ما تتوقعه من اسرائيل
والهجمات على الجنود الامريكيين في سوريا
ترى فيها ايران ضغوطا تمارس على اسرائيل
تحاول ايران ايجاد سبل للرد لكني لا اعتقد
انها نجحت في هذه المساعي
مصر
في معهد واشنطن للدراسات الشرق الادنى
شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه التوضيحات
[تصفيق]
منذ ان اطلقت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الحرب على الارهاب في عام 2001 شنت القوات
الجويه الامريكيه عشرات عمليات الاغتيال
التي استهدفت قاده تنظيمات ارهابيه في
القاعده وكذلك في داعش هذا كان عبر طائرات
مسيره لكن البطل الذي حضر دائما في اغلب
هذه العمليات كان صاروخ اي جي ام 114 هل
فاير صاروخ اي جي ام 114 هل فاير انتجته
شركه لوكيد مارتن في بدايته ودخل الخدمه
عام 1984 كصاروخ مضاد للمدرعات لكن صغر
حجم الصاروخ وخفه وزنه جعله مثاليا
لطائرات المسيره مثل مسيرات ريبر وكذلك
مسيرات بريداتور تم تزويد راس الصاروخ
بمنظومه توجيه جعلته من فئه صواريخ شوت
اند اي اطلق وانسى هذا كان بدقه فائقه
ومدى يصل حتى احد عشر كيلومترا
احدث اصدار للصاروخ كان من طرازه
وهو من الاسلحه الامريكيه السريه الذي
يعرف باسم قنبله النينجا تم استبدال راس
الصاروخ الحربي الشديد الانفجار بسته
شفرات تنطلق من الصاروخ لتمزق الهدف الى
اشلاء دون الحاق اي اذى بمن حوله اشهر
عمليات الاغتيال التي استخدم فيها هذا
الصاروخ كانت تصفيه زعيم تنظيم القاعده
ايمن الظواهري في كابول
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل اكبر مسيره افريقيه تحلق في
سماء جنوب افريقيا قريبا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد جنوب افريقيا تتعاقد على
شراء خمس مسيرات كبيره الحجم محليه الصنع
لاول مره
[تصفيق]
المسيره التي تنتجها شركه ميلكور الجنوب
افريقيا هي مسيره تكتيكيه تسمى ميلكور 380
بحسب الشركه فستكون هذه المسيره منافسا
قويا لنظيراتها من المسيرات التي حتى
تقدمها شركات كبرى حول العالم للمزيد حول
هذه المسيره وكذلك المنظومات الاخرى التي
تنتجها شركه مايلكور الجنوب افريقيا ينضم
الينا السيده مارتينوس الرئيس التنفيذي
للشركه بالسعوديه اولا مصر مارتينيوس اهلا
بك معنا في عسكريتاريا يعني ما الذي يميز
مسيره ميلكور 380 جعلكم تقولون بانها
تستطيع منافسه كبرى المسيرات نظيراتهم
النظيراتها في العالم
لقد استثمرت شركتنا كثيرا من اجل تنويع
الخبرات الموجوده في فريق التطوير في
الشركه اذ يتوفر لدينا طيف واسع من
الخبراء الذين يعملون في مجالات واسعه لا
سيما في حق ل التصميم والتطوير وكذلك في
مجال الالكترونيات والاتصالات المتخصصه
وقد سمح ذلك للشركه بزياده توفير انظمه
لمنتجاتنا داخل مصانعنا وهو عامل من شانه
بطبيعه الحال ان يحد من مخاطر الامداد
عندما يتعلق الامر بمتطلبات الصيانه
واصلاح الانظمه وتحديثها
كما اننا حريصون على ان تكون منتجاتنا
متطابقه مع المعايير والجوده العالميه وهو
ما ييسر عمليه الاستخدام
والمتطلبات اللوجستيه الخاصه لدى الجهات
المستخدمه لهذه الانظمه على وجه التحديد
لكن فيما يتعلق بمسيره ميلكو 380 مصر انتم
لديكم تعاقد مع جيش جنوب افريقيا اين
وصلتم في هذا التعاقد وكذلك هل هناك دول
مهتمه بهذه المسيره اخرى وما هي هذه الدول
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق مع سلاح الجو في
جنوب افريقيا الذي يقوم بموجب الاتفاق
بتجربه وتقييم الطائره المسيره وفقا
لمتطلباته بغيه تزويدنا بملاحظاته حولها
ويتضمن الاتفاق ايضا بعد حالات الاستخدام
العمليات وصولا الى نشر هذه الطائره
المسيره بشكل كامل ويعود السبب في ذلك الى
اننا نفضل العمل مع مستخدمي منتجاتنا
لنفهم احتياجاتهم على الرغم من توفر فريق
فني مقتدر لدى الشركه بالنسبه للنشاطنا
على الصعيد العالمي لدينا وجود كبير في
اكثر من 70 بلدا يتم تسويق منتجاتنا فيها
بفضل كفاءه قسم التسويق في الشركه ولقد
اجرينا قدرا كبيرا من النقاشات رفيعه
المستوى لا سيما بشان الطائره المسيره 380
نحن متفائلون جدا حيال المبيعات
المستقبليه لهذه المسيره
مستر مارتينوس فيما يتعلق بقيود التصدير
هل هناك اي قيود معينه للتصدير تفرضها
عليكم الحكومه في جنوب افريقيا لتصدير هذه
المسيره سواء لدول في الشرق الاوسط او حتى
على مستوى العالم
الجواب هو كلا لان منطقه الشرق الاوسط
كانت تاريخيا زبولا مهما لصناعه الدفاع في
جنوب افريقيا ولم نواجه على مدى السنين
قيودا او عراقيل كبرى بشان هذا النوع من
الصادرات كما تربط حكومات بلداننا علاقات
جيده والدليل على ذلك عدد مشاركات حكومه
جنوب افريقيا في القمم التي عقدت بين
الجانبين
من جهه شركتنا نحن نبذل ايضا جهودا في
مجال توطين صناعه الدفاع في البلد الذي
ننشط فيه الامر الذي يجعل المتطلبات
اللوجستيه والصادرات اكثر كفاءه
لديكم الان ثلاث مكاتب في ثلاث دول
السعوديه وكذلك الامارات وايضا في الهند
كيف عزز وجود مثل هذه المكاتب من مكانتكم
الدوليه كشركه عامله في الصناعات الدفاعيه
وكذلك هل لديكم خطه للتوسع اكثر في
المستقبل ام لا
لقد كان لمكاتبنا الدوليه بشكل عام تاثير
ايجابي على الشركه لاننا نرى انفسنا شركه
عالميه تقدم حلول الدفاع وقد سمح لنا فتح
هذه المكاتب بالعمل مباشره مع مستخدمي
منتجاتنا في كل بلد علاوه على الاستفاده
من العلاقات التي تربط البلد الذي نوجد
فيه بالبلدان المجاوره
الوفاء السوق بالنسبه لنا واسعه وتسمح لنا
باخذ البلدان التي لديها الرغبه في
التعاون مع شركات عالميه مثل شركهنا في
الحسبان واستطيع ان اعطيك مثالا جيدا على
ذلك فاختيارنا للوجود في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه يعود للتعاون والدعم الذي وفرته
الحكومه السعوديه
للجهات الفاعله العالميه من اجل الاستثمار
في السوق المحليه والمساعده في تنميه
قدرات السعوديه في مجال الدفاع وهذا
التوجه يتماشى تماما مع سياسه ورؤيه
شركتنا السعيه الى التوسع
مصر فيما يتعلق بقيود التصدير هل هناك اي
قيود تصدير معينه تفرضها عليكم الحكومه في
جنوب افريقيا سواء فيما يتعلق بمسيره
ميلكون 380 او حتى غيرها من المنتجات التي
تقدمونها في الشركه سواء لدول في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط او حتى لبقيه الدول على
مستوى العالم
ان القاره الافريقيه قاره ناميه الى حد
كبير ولديها الكثير من الامكانات التي لم
تسخر في السابق والصناعه في افريقيا تغيرت
بشكل عام انا شخصيا اكثر ارتباطا بمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط لكننا قمنا بدور كبير في
تطوير منتجات في اسواق افريقيا المحليه
بالاعتماد على المهارات المحليه
مثل مارتينوس الحرب في اوكرانيا انعكست
بشكل كبير على الشركات العامله في مجال
الصناعات الدفاعيه وكان لها اثر سواء في
الخطط الانتاج المتعلقه بالوقت الحالي او
حتى في المستقبل كيف يعني اثرت هذه الحرب
على خططكم سواء الحاليه او المستقبليه في
مساله الانتاج
بالنسبه لتاثير الحرب علينا كشركه مصنعه
نحن على علم ببعض الملاحظات التي صدرت حول
هذا الصراع ويمكن ان اشير في الصدد الى
مساله الموثوقيه والدعم الخاصه بالمنتجات
خلال تنفيذ العمليات وهو ما دفعنا الى
اعداد بعض التصميمات من اجل تعظيم هذه
القدرات الى جانب تطبيق تكنولوجيات جديده
من اجل معالجه اوجه القصور التي ظهرت خلال
تنفيذ العمليات
مصر الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه ميلكور الجنوب
افريقيا بالسعوديه شكرا جزيلا على وجودك
معنا
[تصفيق]
يمكن تقسيم مشاركه هذه المقاتله في حرب
فيتنام الى مرحلتين الاولى في عام
1968 لكنها سحبت بعد اشهر قليله عقب سقوط
ثلاث مقاتلات منها نتيجه اعطال فنيه اما
الثانيه فكانت بين عامي 1972 و 1973 بعد
اصلاح هذه الاعطال بل وتحديثها حيث شاركت
في عمليات القصف الاستراتيجي والتكتيكي
انذاك قامت مجموعه من هذه المقاتلات في
عام
1986 بالاغاره على اهداف في ليبيا هذه
الاهداف تضمنت منزل الزعيم الليبي معمر
القذافي وقتلت فيها ابنته ردا على سقوط
طائره بان امريكان فوق لوكيربي كما شاركت
طائره الاف 10011 في حرب الخليج الاولى بل
واستخدمت بكثافه في شن ضربات بالاسلحه
الذكيه حيث اطلقت ما يقارب من 60 % من
الاسلحه الموجهه بالليزر في الحرب
تقرر في عام 1996 اخراج الاف مئه واحد عشر
من الخدمه هذا كان الارتفاع تكلفتها
التشغيليه الا ان اخر طائراتها
ال563 بقيت تخدم في استراليا حتى عام 2010
والتي كانت بالمناسبه الدوله الوحيده التي
تستخدم هذه الطائرات بخلاف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
حلقه عسكري تاليا لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]